what's not what's natural to cheat for  meant to cheat it's it's but this is  earlier is that if it is natural to  cheat but if you can and if you're  dating the top 20 and you marry them and  you have kids with them then I think  it's also down to you as a woman to be a  woman that they want to be loyal to so  you are having sex with them you're not  holding it as well if you cheated on you  would you would you leave him  I haven't got kids no so without the  kids you would leave yeah but after the  kids you would stay with him  yeah  um yes I would because I'll be putting  the kids first but if it was like a but  if you if she cheats speaking to the mic  please so if she cheats would you leave  I wouldn't stay with any woman who  cheated on me and I never have I love  this I love this and it depends on what  time you're assuming that men and women  are the same we are